so your kids don't stand a chance well
if they're abandoned to a system like
this
left to their own devices to navigate it
their chances of surviving with their
souls and minds intact may not be zero
but the chances aren't great that's for
certain i want to begin by reflecting
again on one moment in the what is a
woman trailer that we played yesterday
on the show uh one of the people we
interviewed scott nugent is a female who
as she says medically transitioned to
appear like a male but will never
actually be a man
now she she speaks out now quite bravely
about her own horrific experiences with
medical transition and warns against
most especially the drugging and
mutilation of children in the trailer
which you can watch at what is a
woman.com nugent says it got me at 42
your child doesn't stand a chance and as
i said yesterday you know we should
understand that your child doesn't
understand a chance and it referring to
you know gender ideology uh but your
child doesn't doesn't stand a chance is
not meant to be a literal guarantee that
all of our children are going to be
indoctrinated into the trans cult
against our will we can protect our kids
against that and we must
the point is to emphasize just how
powerful the forces aligned against
the youngest generations actually are
we often lament that kids in school for
example are exposed to things that only
adults should be exposed to but it's
actually worse than that they are in
fact subjected to things that even
adults are not subjected to
actually the adults who choose to
subject our kids to these things
don't want to be subjected themselves to
the very same thing so case in point a
mom this week confronted the clark
county school board in las vegas
about pornographic material that her
daughter was forced to wasn't just
assigned to her she was forced to
memorize this and present it to her
class
and listen to how the school board
responds though listen to this
i'm going to read you an assignment
given to my
15 year old daughter at a local high
school
this will be horrifying for me to read
to you but that will give you
perspective on
how she must have felt when her teacher
required her to memorize this
and to act it out in front of her entire
class
i don't love you it's not you it's just
i don't like your dick or anything in
that case i cheated joe
i'm sorry
excuse me i i don't thank you so much
for your thank you for your uh comment
forgive me i we're not using profanity
are you
that's relevant
okay the teacher this required my
daughter to read memorize this and read
this pornographic material
excuse me please don't engage with the
audience okay
so please continue your public comment
your your time is you've got one at one
minute and 19 seconds
i ask you simply this is a public
meeting i asked for decorum
and i'm asking
dr jarrah thank you so much dr jara
if you don't want me to read it to you
what was that like for my 15 year old
daughter to have to memorize
pornographic material
so you hear someone in the audience
first cuts her off and says this is
propaganda
it's probably it is propaganda but it's
the propaganda being given to kids in
school and immediately after the mother
there at the microphone
uh said what you heard her say at the
end which is if you don't want to hear
it then why are we giving it to kids
they cut her microphone
they the adults on the school board did
not want to have to hear profanity and
sexual vulgarities but they don't mind
if 15 year old kids are exposed to it
so just think about that for a moment
there are things that kids are subjected
to in schools which would be considered
not only inappropriate but potentially
sometimes illegal anywhere else in
society
adults are able to say things to kids in
school make them do things that in any
other context would lead to that adult
being arrested
if you walked up to a child that was
walking down the sidewalk and you you
handed her the material that the mother
in that video was reading you'd go to
jail
but a teacher can assign it as a
mandatory classroom activity
and the school board will take a don't
ask don't tell approach to it
i don't care if the kids have to hear
that but don't make me listen to it they
say
no kids in school aren't being treated
like adults that would be bad enough the
actual situation is worse here's another
example from today fox news reports the
school board of fairfax county public
schools in fairfax virginia is reviewing
updated rules that could potentially
expose students to suspension or
expulsion for quote maliciously
misgendering their peers based on quote
frequency and intensity
you'll worry about the intensity of the
misgendering the fairfax county public
schools students rights and
responsibilities handbook which will be
voted on may 26th
includes in its updated version rules
that make malicious dead naming and
malicious misgendering of classmates a
level 4 offense which allows for a
suspension of up to five days if
frequency and intensity are present
according to page 19 of the document
using slurs based upon the actual or
perceived gender identity is forbidden
under the rules of the document quote
which includes but it's not limited to
malicious dead naming or malicious
misgendering
now malicious misgendering may sound
like the name of a of an indie band but
actually it refers to the crime of using
a grammatically correct pronoun to refer
to a gender confused person
and dead naming of course means using
the name their parents gave them rather
than whatever name they made up for
their new alter ego
this is a level four offense the good
news is that it's not a level five
offense which means that it's not quite
placed on the same level as homicide and
sexual assault
so fairfax in this way is slightly less
insane than the school district of
wisconsin that we talked about yesterday
that's charging
three boys with sexual harassment for
failing to refer to a quote unquote
non-binary student with they them
pronouns
so this what's happening in fairfax is
actually not as bad as what's happening
in other schools
but the bad news is that level four puts
misgendering on the same tier as assault
theft and
arson so you could like set the school
on fire
and uh or you could refer to a boy as a
he
and it's you know tomato tomato it's the
same thing
and the even worse news is that students
all the way down to kindergarten
will be subjected and subject to these
rules and then the prescribed penalties
which include lengthy suspicion
suspensions or even expulsion
this puts a moral burden
on little kids in elementary school
that the vast majority of adults have
never had to endure i've never had to
endure
because they're being compelled to lie
under threat of immediate and severe
punishment
i've never quite been in a situation
like that have you
they must choose between the truth
or their academic futures
like it's like a seven-year-old kid is
is faced with that
very few adults have shown the resolve
fortitude courage
to stand by the truth on this issue or
any other issue even when the
consequence is merely an unpleasant look
or an uncomfortable interaction
most adults have shown that they will
respect the pronoun
even if they prefer not to simply
because they're afraid of confrontation
they're afraid of awkwardness
there could be nothing else there there
could be no other potential consequence
other than that
and most adults will just go along with
it
how many children will have the strength
to speak the truth retain their sanity
when the consequence will be not only
social alienation but also severe
administrative punishments
now
the rule does stipulate that only
malicious misgendering incidents will uh
be punished and this gives the kids a
little leeway in case they you know make
the mistake of accidentally using proper
grammar
might also give them a little bit of
grace if they uh if they have trouble
keeping up with their classmates who
have a gender identity that changes five
times a day
but if it's decided that proper grammar
was used intentionally god forbid
then the consequences will be swift and
dire
now when i was a kid students with a
demonstrable grasp on the rules of
grammar
were awarded with like high grades and
little encouraging stickers on their
assignments
now those students are expelled
and how will the administration even
know if the misgendering was intentional
or not
well that'll be up to their kangaroo
courts to determine
of course malicious
and intentional are seen as one and the
same here
it's been decided that the only reason
why anybody would ever intentionally use
male pronouns when referring to a male
who wants to be a female is that they're
trying to hurt the person
the possibility that somebody would
misgender i.e correctly gender not
because they want to hurt anybody but
because they value the truth and because
they realize that cooperating with and
affirming confusion only causes more
harm to the confused individual that
possibility is discounted
doesn't exist
as far as the fairfax schools are
concerned
now the effect here is first and
foremost of course that kids are
mentally beaten into submission until
they finally accept the tenants of
gender ideology not because they
understand the tenants or believe them
but because they're afraid
understandably afraid and they lack the
energy or the will to deal with the
consequences of not accepting
what they're being told to accept
but another effect
just as intentional but less often
discussed
is that kids are are
being turned against each other
terry shilling of the claremont
institute made this point on twitter
about this story i thought it was a good
point
that these kinds of policies are on top
of everything else
yet another way to sow division and
suspicion and resentment
within the student population among the
kids themselves
it's announced from on high that any
student who intentionally fails to use
preferred pronouns
is malicious and deserving of the
harshest possible penalties
this is a message and word of warning
not just to those heretical students
but to all the other kids as well it's a
big red arrow pointed at the heretic
saying these people are bad they hate
you you should hate them too
that's the announcement
don't try to see the best in people
don't give any grace
don't try to understand things from
their perspective oh no not that
no if they don't do what you want them
to do report them to the authorities and
destroy their lives
that's the message
the environment that's fostered
so your kids don't stand a chance well
if they're abandoned to a system like
this
left to their own devices to navigate it
their chances of surviving with their
souls and minds intact may not be zero
but the chances aren't great
that's for certain
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated